"Después de la tormenta de nieve del jueves, la
nieve en Chillytown alcanzó 55 cm de profundidad.
El viernes siguió nevando y cayeron varios
centímetros más", ok, está cayendo mucha
nieve. "Ahora, la nieve en Chillytown tiene 84
cm de profundidad. ¿Cuántos centímetros de nieve
cayeron el viernes?" Bien, veamos este diagrama
para imaginar lo que está sucediendo. Entonces,
primero hubo una tormenta de nieve el jueves y la
nieve en Chillytown alcanzó 55 cm de profundidad,
y observa, nos lo muestran justo aquí, este punto
en la regla nos muestra 55 centímetros, así que
esta es la profundidad que tenía la nieve después
la tormenta del jueves, esta profundidad es de 55
centímetros. Pero no paró de nevar, ahora la nieve
en Chillytown tiene 84 centímetros de profundidad,
en la regla este punto nos muestra 84 centímetros,
aquí tenemos 84 centímetros de profundidad. Y
nos preguntan ¿cuántos centímetros de
nieve cayeron el viernes? Es decir,
lo que nos piden a encontrar es esta cantidad
que tenemos por aquí, ¿cuál es la cantidad de
nieve que cayó el viernes? Por eso tenemos este
signo de interrogación -signo de interrogación,
centímetros-, ¿cómo lo encontramos? Bueno,
escribamos algunas cosas que sabemos verdaderas,
sabemos que 55 cm -55 cm- más cualquiera que sea
esta cantidad de centímetros, así que escribiré
signo de interrogación centímetros. Ojo, esta
es la cantidad de centímetros de nieve que
cayó el jueves más la cantidad de centímetros de
nieve que cayó el viernes, esto será igual a la
cantidad total de nieve que cayó, esto será igual
a 84 centímetros. Así que necesitamos encontrar
a qué es igual este signo de interrogación.
Bueno, una forma de encontrar a qué es igual
de este signo de interrogación es pensar que si
55 más el signo de interrogación es igual a 84,
esto significa que 84, 84, menos 55 -menos 55-
es igual al signo de interrogación. Una forma
de verlo es que si tenemos toda la nieve y le
quitamos 55 centímetros de profundidad sólo nos
quedaremos con la cantidad de nieve que representa
el signo de interrogación, porque la diferencia
entre 84 y 55 es la cantidad de nieve que cayó
el viernes, la diferencia entre 84 y 55. Así
que encontremos esta diferencia, tenemos 84 - 55,
esto será igual a nuestro signo de interrogación,
así que primero pensemos en el lugar de las
unidades. Tenemos 4 unidades menos 5 unidades,
bueno, como no podemos hacer esto ya que 4 es
menor que 5, entonces reagrupamos, tomemos 1
decena del lugar de las decenas y, por lo tanto,
en lugar de tener 8 decenas por aquí tendremos 7
decenas, y convertiremos esta decena extra que
acabamos de tomar en 10 unidades, por lo tanto,
10 + 4 es 14. Y ahora podemos restar: 14
unidades menos 5 unidades son 9 unidades,
7 decenas menos 5 decenas son 2 decenas, así que
la misteriosa cantidad de nieve que buscábamos
son 29 centímetros, esta profundidad aquí
son 29 centímetros. Y podemos comprobarlo:
55 + 29 en efecto es igual a 84. Y te invito a que
compruebes que en verdad funciona, por lo tanto,
¿cuántos centímetros de nieve cayeron el viernes?
29 centímetros. Lo más importante en los problemas
como éste es que imaginas la historia, imagina qué
es lo que sucede, y si no hay diagramas dibújalos
tú, luego piensa en escribir algunos enunciados
matemáticos, algunos lo llaman expresiones o
ecuaciones, que sepas que serán verdaderos, con
ello podrás encontrar la respuesta correcta.